dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir as humans when
looking at the world our eyes and brain
does not process the entirety of the
image we have in front of us but plays
an interesting trick on us we can only
see fine details in a tiny tiny fovea
teeth region that we are gazing at while
our peripheral or indirect vision only
sees a sparse blurry version of the
image and the rest of the information is
filled in by our brain this is very
efficient because our vision system only
has to process the tiny fraction of the
visual data that is in front of us and
it still enables us to interact with the
world around us so what if we would take
a learning algorithm that does something
similar for digital videos imagine that
we would need to render a sparse video
with only every tenth pixel filled with
information and some kind of neural
network based technique would be able to
reconstruct the full image similarly to
what our brain does yes that sounds
great but that is very little
information to reconstruct an image from
so is it possible well hold on to your
papers because this new work can
reconstruct a near-perfect image by
looking at less than 10% of the input
pixels so we have this as an input and
we get this Wow what is happening here
is called a neuro reconstruction or
foliated rendering data or you are
welcome to refer to it as foliated
reconstruction in short during your
conversations over dinner the scrambled
text part here is quite interesting one
might think that well it could be better
however given the fact that if you look
at the appropriate place in the sparse
image I not only cannot read the text I
am not even sure if I see anything that
indicates that there is a text there at
all so far the example assumed that we
are looking at a particular point in the
middle of the screen and the ultimate
question is how does this deal with a
real-life case where the user is looking
around well let's see this is the input
and the reconstruction
witchcraft
have a look at some more results note
that this method is developed for head
mounted displays where we have
information on where the user is looking
over time and this can make all the
difference in terms of optimization
you see a comparison here against a
method labeled as multi-resolution
this is from a paper by the name
foliated 3d graphics and you can see
that the difference in the quality of
the reconstruction is truly remarkable
additionally it has been trained on
350,000 short natural video sequences
and the whole thing runs in real time
also note that we often discuss image in
painting methods in this series for
instance what you see here is the
legendary patch match algorithm that is
one of these and it is able to fill in
missing parts of an image however in
image in painting most of the image is
intact with smaller regions that are
missing this is even more difficult an
image in painting because the vast
majority of the image is completely
missing the fact that we can now do this
with learning-based methods is
absolutely incredible
the first author of the paper is Anton
Kaplan who's a brilliant and very
rigorous mathematician so of course the
results are evaluated in detail both in
terms of mathematics and with the user
study make sure to have a look at the
paper for more on that we got to know
each other with Anton during the days
when all we did was light transport
simulations all day every day and were
always speculating about potential
projects and to my great sadness somehow
unfortunately we never managed to work
together for a full project again
congratulations on tone beautiful work
what a time to be alive this episode has
been supported by Linode Linode is the
world's largest independent cloud
computing provider they offer affordable
GPU instances featuring the Quadro r-tx
6000 which is tailor-made for AI
scientific computing and computer
graphics projects exactly the kind of
works you see here in this series if you
feel inspired by these works and you
wish to run your experiments or deploy
your already existing works through a
simple and reliable hosting service make
sure to join over 800,000 other happy
customers and choose Linode to spin up
your own GPU instance and receive a $20
free credit visit linda.com slash papers
or
click the link in the video description
and use the promo code papers 20 during
signup give it a try today our thanks to
Lee note for supporting the series and
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time